this video is brought to you by under
luckystars.com
[Music]
so chuck you know i love me some van
gogh this is true vincent van gogh
in particular starry night absolutely
and
i have a copy of it behind my desk i see
it it is an actual oil painting yes it
is
wait that means somebody did that yes
yes that's an actual oil painting
it's actually the original but don't
okay all right there we go
so that will not be here later today
you told the wrong person actually the
museum of modern art had a garage sale
right
i got it for
so what i like about it is
it's clearly not exactly what he saw
right because the sky doesn't really do
that
with the swirls and the turbulence but
it's no doubt what the sky felt like
to him and for me art at its best
captures the emotion of reality
rather than the reality if i want
reality i'll just take a picture i don't
i don't need you to paint reality right
for me
well no that makes sense no it's like
people who say i love the hubble
telescope and their pictures
here's my painting of that hubble
picture right it's like
no give me the hubble picture right
exactly all right otherwise give me an
interpretation
of reality then we then we fully tap
what the creativity of an artist can
bring to the table
so i have not only up there on my second
book i used it for the cover oh wow look
at that yeah
and look and a nice little plug here too
uh universe down to earth
this is it starry night van gogh that
was my second book
did i ever plus it's also hold on
yeah it's i have an eyeglass case where
they get some gum in it women here
here we go my class case is is mango
look at that glass holder not only that
not only that i got some mango oh
my god you're back in my phone so i got
van gogh everywhere in this office plus
you're sitting on one that's one of the
pillows i didn't go reaching you get it
okay there it goes wow this is one of my
my plush pillows nice and it used to
work where you squeeze the moon
and then the stars would light up but
somebody sat on and broke the
electronics
so i i got to i got to get back in there
oh it wasn't me
but there's the cypress tree the sleepy
village the rolling hills
painted in 1889 in june in france
this location is known so so
that's actually a real time and a real
place the that's a crescent moon on the
far right
and all evidence tells us that the
bright white object
with the swirls around it is the planet
venus
oh so this is the early morning before
sunrise so that's the
this he's really seeing the sky yeah and
he's getting some of his getting some of
it
some fundamentals and the rest is his
interpretation of it
okay and what i like most about this
painting
i think it's i i could be wrong but i
checked this
i think it's the first painting ever
that was
named for what was drawn in the
background
right because think about it he could
have called it
cypress tree he could have called it
study of a cypress tree he could have
called it
sleepy village he could have called it
church steeple
he could have called it rolling hills
which is in the sort of the mid-ground
or he could have called it i can't sleep
okay
but he called it the start
and for me that was the universe working
its way
into the artist's vocabulary right
so if you know the date and the time
right you can
know the sky yeah which is why i was
able to get you this
i'm serious this is your gift story
night this is the actual sky
so it's not an interpretation okay this
is the stars in the night sky
this is a representation of the stars
and the nights when he painted when he
painted that well thank you
and starry night of course is the title
the title because
it's the sky itself well thank you
you're welcome
this and so because we we can know what
the sky is in the past for any time of
day and every and all events
any time day any event we can know what
it is and there is a a
place that i love called under
luckystars.com
and um people that can appreciate this
type of gift i love to give them like
for
you it's starry night for my wife it was
the night that we met
it could be the birth of your child it
could be
uh the day you got married it could be
any event that you want to
uh commemorate by the sky
itself being represented for that event
well i
i like this guy so i got a feeling that
you do
you know something tells me you keep
looking up for some reason oh yeah
that's right
yeah we end every show that way yeah
exactly keep looking up
there we go yeah on my ceiling actually
when i was a kid i had
uh glow-in-the-dark stars on my ceiling
yeah yeah yeah well now you can actually
hang this on the ceiling
no i'm joking don't do that but no it's
i mean i i hope you like it i'm dead
seriously thank you
i really do thank you you know and um
and and and by the way
if you wanted to you can go to
underluckystars.com and do the same
for any occasion it's very simple very
easy
very clean and it's a great way to let
the cosmos be the gift itself
i figured you liked that that's
beautiful
this is beautiful you can make your own
star map
by going to underluckystars.com they've
been in business since 2016 making them
the first
custom star map maker a star map is a
great way to commemorate important
events
like when you first met your sweetheart
birthdays engagements
weddings and more choose a date
customize the title and select your
design
and this is very important for star talk
fans the maps have been verified by a
nasa astronomer for accuracy
which you can read all about on under
luckystars.com
don't wait go to underluckystars.com
today
and order right away be a star and
give the stars to your star